you don't need an office you don't need
a 25 grand startup loan you don't need
loads of stock you don't need a factory
a production line or
any of that stuff it can literally be
you and a laptop and
the information that you have or some
kind of service you're looking to
provide
it feels like we're missing something
today i know i know
the the third square missing a squad
shaped like this like raisin an almond
scone-shaped hole uh yusuf is saving
lives uh whereas me and you just spend
all our time on the internet
so i thought i'd get a hold of you today
and just record a
a rogue podcast what are we going to be
talking about
well the internet basically or how how
people make money
using the internet so i guess the broad
subject would be online business
building an online business starting an
online business
you can't make money anywhere else there
is no money to be made in real person at
the moment
yeah yeah well i suppose like
even people who go to offices or have
worked in an office their entire life
are now basically living the same life
as someone who's
been a like a digital entrepreneur their
entire life so everyone's working from
homes a lot of remote working
but yeah so i suppose this is something
that
i've been doing with yusuf for quite a
while
um since 2010-ish officially
i think we actually incorporated the
business i don't know whether you know
this chris but i think we actually
incorporated
propane in your flat in jesmond
yeah i seem to remember that so you've
been running an online business for over
a decade
and now the main source of your business
is teaching other people to run an
online business so if there is anybody
on the internet that can tell us what
how to start an online business how not
to it's you
well i mean that's very kind of you i
can i can certainly talk about
the the the pros and cons and the kind
of the common mistakes so we do
uh fitness coaching and then the other
side of what we do is i guess
teaching people who do fitness coaching
to use the internet to teach fitness
coaching
and that's that's kind of so you know
helping helping pt's a lot of personal
trainers at the moment are
um obviously they can't train clients so
a lot of them are using the internet
using an online based service to coach
clients and that
i think a lot of them have run into this
problem of like i'll just do a zoom
thing
i'll just get people on and then you're
like oh actually
there's quite a lot to this it's quite
complicated um
and then we step in to help so that's
kind of uh
what gives me any kind of right to talk
about this i guess you've got you've got
license to talk about it man so where do
we
where do we begin like what are the why
would someone even want to start
a business on the internet
it's a good question i think why did i
want to start a business on the internet
that's probably the best place to
explain that from so um i started out of
university i went into it like a typical
nine to five
grower it's not nine to five supposed to
be nine to five you have to sign that
bit of paper that means that you're
they can basically make you work as many
hours as you want um and i was driving
to work listening to i think the book
that
every anyone with a hint of
entrepreneurial desire has read which is
the four hour work week
um and in that book if you've not read
it by a guy called tim ferriss
he talks about basically starting a
business as this kind of way to
um live the live the life live life on
your terms so you have more command over
your
when you work where you work how much
money you make etc
and the multiple currencies and uh he
refers that to that as a muse
so you build a business that's kind of
small you're not trying to build the
next facebook you're not trying to
conquer the world
you're trying to earn a living selling
something um
typically through like maybe through
like a drop shipping process which i
guess we'll talk about
shortly um or selling information
getting it to the point where you can
actually leave
the constraints of the typical employed
life
and work for yourself and i guess a lot
of people
even as they progress through a career
um realized that basically
in this cycle of um i am working
for a salary i have to go to a certain
place
and i get paid a certain amount and i
have to work for this amount of time
otherwise that i don't get the paycheck
at the end of the month
and i think you only need to know one
person who
doesn't fit that mold and to be honest i
think it was you for me chris
he was like the the one friend who's
like yeah but he
he earns more than than my friends and
he doesn't have to go he doesn't have to
put a tie on he doesn't have to
wear a shirt and he doesn't have to
travel to stockton every morning to go
and
audit a manufacturing plant um so like i
think
you know everyone you just have to know
one person you start to question these
things and you read these books and i
think
now um a lot of people are having
similar questions when you know they've
been
forced to work from home or perhaps even
lost their job for various reasons
it's like what else could i do that's
maybe less reliant on
somebody else or another company why do
online business
rather than just progressing what you're
currently doing in the real world
in terms of what's the reasons for it
what are the benefits why not just
be start your own accountancy firm leave
the accounting firm you're out and start
your own as opposed to becoming like an
online accountant somehow or
selling online accountancy how to be an
accountant courses
or how to be a coach to coach
accountants to move online
yeah well to be honest i think one of
the easiest ways to do something like
this
is actually to take a skill you already
have and just do it for yourself
online um so i suppose the what i
immediately think of when i think of
online business and why someone would
want to start it
is it's usually some kind of
informational
information transaction right so it's a
service or it's selling advice or it's
selling information
um there are others but that's a very
common type
and the reason for that is it doesn't
really involve the traditional
uh structure that you think a normal
business would would require
so you don't need an office you don't
need a 25 grand startup loan
you don't need loads of stock you don't
need a factory a production line
or any of that stuff it can literally be
you and a laptop um and the information
that you have or
some kind of service you're looking to
provide and the missing piece of that
puzzle
is clients i guess um and a way to help
them but if you get yourself into the
position where you have clients in a
business like that
it can be extremely profitable because
the costs are
nothing basically all the costs are you
your time and the software and the
technology
that you need so the low barriers to
entry in terms of not needing massive
amounts of investment
financially and the
low skill barrier to entry i suppose as
well that
you are for a lot of people with their
online business repurposing existing
knowledge that you already have
and then just putting it out into the
universe
to see i think it's was it you that told
me everyone is an expert in something
yeah so that there's a few people online
that really promote that
that message that like if you the more
you think about it
if you had to i think we spoke about
this on maybe a life hacks episode where
one of the bits of advice i gave was try
in some way to think like how would i
monetize myself and i don't mean like
set up an only fan's account i mean how
can although that you know arguably
they're making more money than all of us
so yeah they're the ones winning
um but yeah like i i know some people
personally who
who worked as like an engineer or
something that you wouldn't necessarily
think
um could be translated online
but they were receiving a salary and
then they left that set up on their own
and now they're kind of consulting
are in the same capacity earning three
four
times the amount um so
i suppose it's going from taking
something that you're maybe doing for
somebody else
in the confines of a business and they
are paying you kind of what they think
that's worth
but the market may think that's worth
more right someone else or multiple five
six ten customers may think well i'll
pay a monthly fee for that advice or
i'll pay
a fee for access to help and then
consulting on that
a specific thing so
yeah there's there is still a barrier to
entry i think that
just to quickly cover the the
misconception here and i think
the mike winner you've had on twice now
yeah once or twice so his his youtube
channel and the idea behind the
entrepreneur is
there is a big movement in the online
world that if you buy
some course and set up a webinar or
something like that
you can suddenly have an online business
and i
i i get the idea of it and obviously the
people selling the course i'm sure make
a lot of money out of it but i think
just because a business is online it
doesn't mean that demand and supply and
like the basic principles of why someone
purchases something
don't apply they definitely do so if you
have something valuable
or you have a service or some knowledge
or some expertise that is valuable to
someone else
in the sense that you can shorten the
gap from a to b
like i'm trying to learn to slackline
right how do i slack i've got no idea
well i could just work with someone
who's an expert in slacklining and
they'll make me slackline in 12 weeks
for example right so that i mean that's
a service that you could be turned into
a course or a service
and i don't think anybody could say that
like if
that's your goal you want to learn a
slackline and you learn to slackline
that you've done anything wrong by
selling somebody that information all
that help
right you've delivered a valuable
service and you can use the internet to
do that
in a very highly like profitable way
that doesn't you don't have to sell to
people on your street or in your town
you can sell the people anywhere in the
world
so the scale and the ability to leverage
two of the main points i think people
entering the online world won't
necessarily be familiar with those words
but
the naval managers certainly helped and
people like jack butcher talk about it
an awful lot on the internet um
you can only do one pt session at a time
but if you make a course that people can
follow passively
you can have a million people do it it's
not like you need to say that word a
million times to every single person
that's watching
uh you don't get a call in the middle of
the night at 3am like right johnny
such and such is doing some chess press
over in adelaide you're gonna have to
get up and like
and skype him so that he understands
what he's doing so
that's certainly one of them and you
touched on kind of the dark
secret of the classic nine to five world
which is that
the amount of security that you get from
your job
is offset by you not capturing the
upside
of whatever the transaction is with the
person that's paying for you and that
really is like for so many businesses
especially
looking at covid this year the people
who
should have been the most worried were
the totally usef
useless fluff filler middle management
like
like the the regional manager of hr
like why do you need you've got a guy in
each town and you've got a director of
hr
the guy that's in between is basically
there to make
the guy the tops life easier and the guy
at the bottom's life harder
but the person that actually delivers
the value is the person who is
cranking the widgets and the person who
coordinates everything is the guy that
does strategy up at the director's
office
so very often there is within a business
the person at the bottom can't be
afforded they can't afford really to pay
that person much more
because they have all of these different
layers of bureaucracy to make sure that
that person at the bottom is actually
doing their job
so if you as the person at the bottom
who can do the job and knows that you're
reliable and maybe has the business
acumen
to think right i i can go to the market
maybe i understand branding maybe i'm
quite good at copywriting maybe i've got
a bit of an
i or i've got some existing contacts
within the industry
i can perhaps try and pivot this online
so what do what are the common
types of online business what are the
most common ones that people use
so i think there's a lot there's there's
common types that a lot of people try
that don't necessarily last very long
well what are those
so i think like everyone's seen an ad
for
like forex trading for example or
drop shipping is a very common one um
you know like making money through drop
shipping stuff on amazon and you hear
that you're like i don't know what any
of those words mean but it sounds great
um so you know the stuff that um
i suppose is easier to to conceptualize
you think okay i'm gonna
buy something from overseas and ship it
and then sell it and i can run it all
from my laptop
and obviously there are businesses that
run like that and they're immensely
successful
but i'd say most people who try that
don't succeed because there's
there's like operational risk with that
you've got to actually you're moving
physical things around and you can get
that wrong
forex markets um we've just released a
podcast if you saw having a bad
experience and stuff like that i think
it was on life fails life hack fails you
so i spoke about that
so that has its downsides as well um
so i think the most common type of
online business that i see
consistently succeed is basically
exactly what we what we spoke about
where
um copywriting or
consulting larger businesses or
obviously personal training
right things that can can quite easily
to be honest be taken
from an offline here i am in the flesh
speaking to you telling you what to do
in a one to one or maybe a one to three
or four if you're doing group based
stuff
now i'm gonna package the the knowledge
that i would typically deliver in that
session
i'm going to put it into videos text
like
stuff that appears on a screen that
anyone can access whenever they want or
i'm going to
do the same coaching but but virtually
that's a very
um especially if you've already got the
knowledge and expertise it's a very low
cost
very like despite what a lot of people
think there's a lot of
technical know-how that at this point
there really isn't um
so that i'd say that was the the most
common so and that i would even argue
that people who
you don't have to have a course right or
an ebook or something like that for it
to be an online business i think if you
are using the internet
to deliver the service and you are doing
it remotely
and you are working with a client or
multiple clients i'd say that's an
online business
right you don't have to have a members
area or any book to sell
um so i know people who are accountants
who do this
or as i say engineers who do this who do
consulting-based work but they work for
themselves
and their businesses all remote all
online
yeah so i guess that kind of changes the
dynamic of an online business a little
bit you're not necessarily
delivering i mean my accountant delivers
his product to me
via email i wouldn't consider him to be
an
online businessman despite the fact that
chris probably hasn't been into his
office
for a year he doesn't need to um so yeah
that's an interesting way to look at it
what about principles
say there's someone that's listening
that thinks i have some expertise or
maybe i'm
a pt who's considered i mean go to
propane fitness.com
modern wisdom if you're a pt that wants
to pivot online but
if you're just someone who's thinking
right i want to get started in the
online world
what are the principles what should they
focus on getting right
first yeah so that's
i suppose when people this is the most
common failure point is the starting
point and it's the
the rabbit hole the one of ten rabbit
holes that you can go down and spend
months down
without actually gaining any kind of
traction and that's the common stuff
like
online business needs that means i need
um
an expensive website worried about
whether it should be purple or green
um or maybe even building out a program
or building materials doing cash flow
forecasts and all this sort of stuff and
i think
basically you can have all of that right
but ultimately not have a customer and
not have any revenue
you technically don't really still have
a business to speak of
um so the example i always give our
students is like yusuf and i
ran uh propane fitness for quite a while
from
microsoft word like that that was it
um well and the email obviously we
weren't just typing
typing documents to ourselves so we were
yeah i wrote this really long document
and i just kept paying myself it was
great now we uh
we would email clients from our personal
email and it would all be done through
word
there was not really a website in place
everything through paypal or something
probably
exactly submitted invoices a nightmare
nightmare um it's the sort of thing
yousef has recurrent nightmares about
now
but um the point is is that like the why
did it work
i have this thing that i'm trying to do
and i'm struggling
or i have this thing in my life that i'm
trying to get rid of or solve
and i don't really know how to do it
myself so i'm looking for a solution and
that's everything down from
a consumer like a you and i looking to
solve a problem or
a business or an organization looking to
solve a problem and want to get someone
in remotely
if you're solving something like that
then
someone somewhere will pay to have that
problem solve or that goal
process accelerated for them and that's
basically where you step in as a
as a business as an offering if you get
that bit right
you can make a lot of mistakes and still
kind of succeed
you can you can get a lot of the
technicals wrong and still have
happy clients basically what's the
question that you're asking yourself to
try and work out whether you've got that
right
is it is there a market for the thing
that i'm trying to give
you have this hypothesis which is like i
think this kind of person wants
this kind of thing right i think this
sort of person wants this pro once this
problem solved or wants to reach this
goal
and often times and again this is four
hour work week advice
scratching your own itch is a pretty
easy way to start right like i like so
yusef and i started propane fitness
because
we were really into fitness and we'd had
a really elongated struggle
figuring it all out and we knew we could
compress five years into five months for
someone else
so that's quite an easy one easy way to
start so we knew there was already a
demand there because people were asking
us for it
um or it's like how can i test that
assumption
so asking friends and family asking on
your social media
you know i'm thinking about doing this
for this sort of person do you think
anyone would be interested do you know
anyone what's an expedited way of doing
that just posting online
i think going to your social circle yeah
like your personal facebook your
personal social media and saying
you know i'm going to start this new
thing this new venture it's going to be
doing
this sort of service for this kind of
person or this kind of business do you
know anyone that might
be interested just have a conversation
with them and see if it's right because
if
one person's got the problem and they're
like you know what i'm happy to just pay
you
for that that tells you something pretty
important that you know if there's one
person there's probably going to be more
than one
chris sparks has an interesting
heuristic he uses for this where he says
what
do people often ask you for advice on
so a lot of the time you might be the
the tech
techie guy the guy that understands what
the new gadgets are that are coming out
or how to set up your iphone properly or
you might be the guy that's in good
shape or the guy that can cook
interesting meals or the guy that
raised his kids to not be complete brats
all of those things that people come to
you and say man like you know
i love how charlie and david are just so
well behaved like what did you do with
them
and then you look at someone like
savannah matosian who i had on the show
a couple of months ago he was raising
children
then decided i quite enjoy raising
children and people like my methods i'm
going to document it on patreon and now
him and his wife have a business
that's a business like i know it's run
through patreon which is
again you it's not the most flash of
websites you've involved a third party
they're taking a commission they're
doing all right there's no
fancy landing page at retargeting but
it's making money on the internet
selling expert knowledge exactly
we we've been in programs where you know
you'll kind of interact with other
people who are
also running a business online and i
think a lot of people assume like oh
everybody doing this
is selling how to make money online
right and that's the only business that
can work
there was a guy on this on this call who
was he had the biggest business
by anybody by quite a margin and he was
teaching guitar teaching
he was just teaching people how to play
the guitar on the internet and doing
like multiple hundreds of thousands per
month doing that
and you're just like how you know but
but at the core of it it's like well
why is he successful well a lot of
people want to learn to play the guitar
probably in 2020
this kind of time maybe more than ever
it's like it's a
home i've got a guitar i've never played
it i'm going to take a guitar playing
course
and he's doing really well so it doesn't
even have to be the thing that you do
professionally
it doesn't have to be well if i'm an
accountant i'm going to load the
examples you mentioned there
um it's often like the passion or the
thing that you have that you're like
obsessed with
that a lot of friends would ask you for
help about and if you were to turn that
into a
product or an offering because you know
so much about it because it's the thing
that you're always reading and learning
more about
it ends up being pretty good okay i
think you produce so
that's the first principle make sure
that there's an actual market for what
you're going to create
and don't obsess over fancy website
fancy branding getting an office getting
a backdrop getting a flower wall none of
that what's next
i think the next thing would be so
ideally you
you don't want to get into a one-to-one
based business if you can um just but
it's a great way to start but
you are very constrained long-term if
you want to try and grow that you're
limited by hours in the day it's kind of
the same problem
however if you're going to produce
something you're going to make a course
or
make anything that you're going to sell
i think the best way to do that is to do
it with
customers so trying to try to get into
conversations with a few people
through research through figuring out is
does this problem actually exist
even if it's for free um and they're not
paying you initially but
build the thing that you're going to
offer to the market
with the the help and input of people
who are actually
that market because i think if we assume
it's a
standard kind of information-based
business so the the area we know the
the most is is fitness right so if
someone if if yousef and i have just
made
a lot of our fitness programs from what
we found interesting
it would have been way over the heads of
a lot of our customers
and the example i use a lot is like we
do get people to join the program and
say
which foods have protein in like which
food should i eat that protein you're
like surely
like surely no one's asking that
question right but if we don't cover
that in the program
it's a bad experience for the customer
so i think making the service if you've
got the expertise the challenge is
what is it like to not have the
expertise like what was that like again
how how does it feel to completely not
understand all the stuff that i
understand now how can i help someone
acquire the same information well
i'm going to work with someone who
doesn't have the information i'm going
to try and figure out what the best way
to do that is
and what you end up with is a really
good offering
for the customer not just what you think
is interesting or what you think's
the right thing for you that makes sense
that's a common
error that people make right making a
product that they think that they want
themselves
yeah that doesn't fit the market at all
exactly and it's either too basic or too
advanced a lot of the time
yeah i guess another online business
that we haven't touched on yet is
becoming some sort of creator whether
that be instagram
influencers starting a podcast starting
a youtube um
and i can say from personal experience
that if you're starting a podcast with
the hopes that it's going to be the
thing that you make money from
like just do something else because
it's it's such a slow long burner
to get yourself to the stage where you
can even begin to monetize
where you can even get advertisers to
take one look at you
and then to move from that stage to the
stage where the amount of money
starts to remotely be worth your time on
an hourly wage
again that's not a thing and if you're
doing it for the money you're going to
run out of gas pretty quickly
whereas if you're just doing a thing
that you enjoy it doesn't really matter
the money comes and when it comes it
doesn't it doesn't and that's
kind of what i found but i think we made
on youtube in the first year the ad
revenue that we made in total
was somewhere in the region of about 75
pounds and we've done
we've done 50 episodes
maybe more than 50 episodes by then um
and there's this
sort of rule uh urban myth rule that's
floating around on the internet that it
takes 150 episodes of a podcast before
you can monetize it
now you can actually hasten that
obviously you could do that in a year if
you're doing three a week which is where
i'm at now
then you could you could do that in a
year but most people are doing one a
week which means
you're going to be doing a podcast for
three years before you can even start to
sell ads
so again joe rogan getting a
many many million pound deal from
spotify is amazing and
logan paul and russell brand getting
taken off off normal
podcasts and put behind a paywall and
sam harris monetizing in another way all
of that stuff's great
but the typical way that people make
money from podcasts and from youtube
is with a combination of baked in ie
the hey guys this episode is brought to
you by and
the ad revenue adverts that you have to
skip on youtube on the way past
you need to be doing an awful lot
of plays before you can get to that
stage which means you're going to be
very very disappointed and unfulfilled
for a long time
before you get there but again as i said
the beauty is if what you're doing is
something you enjoy it kind of doesn't
matter
you're just going to be on the treadmill
taking over taking over and
if and when the money comes then
fantastic but yeah it can be it'll be a
miserable miserable process if you want
if you're doing it for a cash return so
that
i think there's two in like the online
business world there's two
camps really there's there's like the
direct response world which is
have a product or an offering get
someone to click a link and
in to enter their email address and then
buy it and that's the way that you build
your business and then the other side is
more the branding side
which is pretty much what you've spoken
about where you know you spend
five years building this audience this
interested audience and then
you sell something to that audience and
it does incredibly well
and i think where we sit is is somewhere
between the two
i think there's value in in both of
those and i think both of them done to
their extreme
have a lot of downsides um but isn't
youtuber is still like the most desired
career right
number one number one career that
children between the age of five and
eight want to be is youtuber
it used to be like doctor policeman
firefighter uh
astronaut us yeah you like none of that
it's like youtubers number
one uh and little do they know that what
they're gonna spend almost all of their
time doing
is looking at a camera and forgetting
the line that they just wrote below it
on a on a laptop
and going ah [ __ ] dean like and that's
it that's what you do you spend your
time thinking of ideas i'm currently the
big push for this year is to
do what i can with the modern wisdom
youtube started trickling some of those
proper monologue videos out
and um it's only when you get really
really deep into the weeds
of the video creators tim schmoyer who's
this youtube affiliated coach
uh seth's done his course i'm going
through at the moment um
or that any one of a million ali abdul
even him in his course
when you get really deep into the weeds
you realize just how sophisticated
youtube is
like mr beast if you've seen his videos
very very successful youtuber
i know it might appear like most of the
videos just like hey guys we're going to
see what happens if we put one million
footballs in this park but that has
taken
months of planning mr beast has two
people that work for him
and all that they do is give him 300
video titles every week and then he goes
through and goes like no no no no no
no maybe no no no no maybe maybe like
that's it
300 video titles every single week and
then from there they just iterate down
it right down it right down
that is oh my god i mean so that i've
see i have seen those videos where it's
like everything you can fit in this
circle
i'll pay for and my first question is
like how is he funding that
i mean the ad
fairly insane but yeah it's not just the
sort of thing that you tumble into but
that being said if you have the passion
to talk about
politics or football or philosophy or
cooking or whatever
like happily start a youtube channel or
a podcast about it
personally if it's a business
if that's the goal i just think that
you are starting off on such a back foot
because the metric of success that you
have chosen to judge your project by
is the final thing which is going to
arrive into your project
way way way after late night
and awkward conversations and your
partners saying what the [ __ ] you
spending time on your laptop for again
and all of those different things all of
those are going to occur first
and well i think that in four years time
i might be able to start charging
like 10 pound cpm for adverts on my
channel
isn't going to cut it and it's also not
going to motivate you so
yeah it's a fantastic thing to do as a
hobby it's also a fantastic thing to do
to um further enhance an existing
platform
here's an interesting thing i i can't
remember the podcast but george put it
in our
modern wisdom chat talking about the
reverse direction now of people who
begin with
audiences and then create a product for
the audience did you see that
yeah can you explain what it means and
kind of just give us your thoughts on it
so i can't i can't
explain the i haven't read the art full
article but i'm aware of like the
the general concept so i think the
it's kind it's linked back to what i was
saying before so you either view it as
um i'm gonna what i was what i was
talking about like build this product to
solve this problem
and the audience will kind of build
around that so
as you get customers and you get leads
and you get people becoming aware of
what you've done
that creates the audience as a result of
like the the economic activity the
buying the sales the revenue
and the other way around is the is the
opposite so you make a channel
or some kind of platform where people
are
have this common interest or this common
problem and then you solve that problem
for them with a with a product
and it i suppose the difficulty is is
that
with with just making and with trying to
make content to build an audience
there's a lot of guessing
involved and there's also you still have
to live somehow
in the in the interim but you still got
to pay yourself
from something a lot of people you see
so ali abdel's a great example right
he's recently
he's quite public about it he released
his youtube account the name of it
youtube
creator something is this this course
seems to have done extremely well from
it
right but when he started his channel he
wasn't doing it
to try and earn a living he was working
as a doctor and was working as a doctor
for most of the time that he was doing
it
which has allowed him to put in two
three years
of just regular high quality content
almost without even mentioning
the financial side of it so what he's
really done there is he's built this
audience of people
who a lot of time probably look at him
and think i want to create a youtube
channel i want to create a new channel i
want to do this too
he's built this audience with a common
problem and then he swept in with the
with the solution to the problem and
been paid very
very well for it so yeah there are there
are pros and cons to both i think the
way
the way we do it is we have podcasts to
as you mentioned we have podcasts to
support
an existing business and the podcasts
aren't getting anywhere near modern
wisdom number downloads
um but they do very well in bringing
customers into the business
and it's weird like we we make way more
from the podcast directly attributed
than we'd ever make through
throughout revenue just by chatting
about the subject
right because people like to listen to
it so it it does really
i think it really depends on what as
well on top of like what are you going
to do
and who you're going to work with it's
it's kind of like what
how do you want to spend your time right
how do you want to spend a day
because as you mentioned the reality of
being a youtuber
is probably a little bit different it's
not just going around supermarkets with
a trolley and giving it to someone
itself but everything you get but
you know there's a lot of prep there's a
lot of monotony there's a lot of saying
the same sentence ten
times and getting it wrong ten times in
a row and all that sort of stuff
um but that's so that's i would kind of
start with that
like how do you wanna if you've got an
idea in mind how do you wanna spend a
day an average day
what does that look like and then which
platforms or which
um business models but most suit that
yeah so if you're if you're the sort of
person
who likes to be wordy and likes to talk
and has things to say and is kind of
outgoing
then a platform where you end up talking
face to camera might be a great idea
but if you're someone who's more
analytical and introverted and wants to
tinker with figures
then perhaps creating a course or
selling an ebook and then retargeting
and
using ads maybe a little bit more
appeals three that's a starting with the
end goal
of what is the sort of life that you
want to live in mind because very much
the degrees of freedom you have when
starting an online business are much
greater than those when you go into a
typical job
like do you what what do you want to do
today is not a question that your boss
often asks you
like you don't get that when you walk in
right mate how are you feeling today do
you want to do
a bit analytical a little bit more sort
of creative like you don't get that
um but when it's you at the beginning of
whatever
entrepreneurial side hustle main hustle
online business it is that you start
you are putting yourself onto a
particular trajectory
and presumably as well the longer that
you go down that road the more difficult
it's going to be it's either wasted time
or a direction that you're going to have
to turn around and come back from
yeah um it's interesting actually
because i
hearing you say that like you're
i remember when a big chunk of your week
was spent
driving from manchester at three in the
morning
to back to newcastle and then getting
three hours sleep and then
waking up and having to go and take the
blow up t-rex down from the club and
moving the flower wall down and now your
day is very very different
yeah so i suppose and i realize
obviously nightclub's one of the
one of the businesses that can't really
be done online um
but you've very much i i guess that the
way that an average
day looks like for you now is a lot more
it's certainly a lot more enjoyable
there's a lot fewer late nights sleeping
patterns a hell of a drug man
it's uh it's wonderful to wake up and go
to bed at the same time yeah honestly
crazy
all right so what are the most common
mistakes we've talked about someone not
understanding that they have a
um product market well there's a market
for their product
also product market fit is the product
that they're creating for the market
actually what it
wants in terms of that delivery don't
[ __ ] about
getting an expensive website don't spend
ages building yourself an office what
else where else do people
what do they think is going to make the
difference which completely does not
i think um there's definitely an
assumption
that i'm just going to post on instagram
and
it'll work like i i've even heard that
sentence or variations from that
sentence from people who
um it's pretty common if someone's like
outside of the fitness industry so that
maybe a personal trainer
they worked in the gym for a bit they
decided the 5am start wasn't for them
they now are working somewhere else in a
different industry and they think i want
to make online a go i'm going to build
an online business
and we have a chat with them they go i'm
going to i'm just going to post on my
instagram and i'll get i'll get five or
ten clients and then
then uh we'll work together and you try
and convey
how it's really not that simple but if
you don't if you've never tried that
before
why would that not work right because
influencers do that you see people doing
swipe ups and
linking bios and all this sort of stuff
and it seems to work for them why would
it not work for me so
i suppose thinking that it's um
thinking that this this just because you
start talking about it that people are
gonna care
thinking that you have a link or you
have something that you've made
something that people are going to care
um is probably the next stumbling block
and i think
that this is the point where people
start giving up when they've been
posting on social media
for 30 days set themselves a 30-day
challenge in january 2021 i'm going to
post every day
on my in my my business instagram and
they don't make a sale
and they think they're doing something
wrong um so
that sort of thing um lots of busy work
lots of uh copying someone who's
famous doing similar things to them
thinking that that's all there is to it
what's the assignment is it people
people being mistaken around how hard it
is to get
others to part with their cash on the
internet
yeah i think so or more that like not
maybe
appreciating the gap between you know
that what you've got
is good you know that your service is
good and that you can really help
someone but
no one else knows that and actually
someone's
less likely to trust you on the internet
than really any any other part of your
life so
you know if you the the advice we give
our clients is you don't
need to if you're if you're solving a
problem you don't often need to convince
the customer that they need the problem
solving i kind of know that
like i kind of know that i want to lose
weight or whatever it is it's just that
i
there's 10 reasons why i don't want it
to be you like this
like i don't i don't trust you who the
hell are you what's this
why she like you know this is a scam so
unless you're going to overcome those
somehow
i'm just never going to pay any
attention to what you're doing so
there has to be something online as part
of your process and this is
what's often referred to as the sales
funnel in a business or the like the
sales sequence the customer journey
that starts to help somebody else see
why you might be able to help them
um because the like the build it and
they will come strategy of i've got a
website with a product on and
a link to buy so i'm going to post about
on instagram and hope that people
kind of find their own way through it
works for some people
if they something they do goes viral for
some reason suddenly they've got huge
audiences and they get one percent of
that audience to purchase
but most people don't achieve that and
most people will always fall short
so i think just thinking basically what
you're doing
in an online business if you're reaching
someone who doesn't know who you who you
are
you're walking up to someone in the
street and saying here's the link can i
give me a yeah it's not going to work
so you have to treat them like a it's
the dating analogies used a lot
right you don't ask for marriage on the
dance floor
so there's steps in between and you've
got to create that experience online
and that's where it starts getting like
oh there's quite a lot of work involved
in this and this is actually quite
difficult
but that's the reality there is quite a
lot of work involved it's a very
nice way to live it's a very um
rewarding outcome
to have like a high profit margin
business but it isn't as easy as a lot
of people
imply it to be what about if it's a
lower ticket product i'm selling an
e-book on gumroad
about how to save money or something
like that i know yousef has some very
strong opinions around this do i need a
big fancy sales funnel for that or can i
just post on my instagram
so gumroad has got a bit of a got a bit
of attraction on twitter
i i don't think anyone really knows why
there's like a trust issue i think
on twitter in some places um it's
certainly easier
uh but the other side of that is just
because it's a lower price
doesn't mean that it's a lower
percentage of what someone's willing to
spend
if that makes sense like if i if i want
to achieve like
back to the weight loss example if i
want to lose weight i really want to
lose weight and i'm
serious about it and i've got some money
to invest i'm going to look at the seven
pound 99 ebook as like well
the answer's not going to be in there
right otherwise i would have found it
already
so but the person who might be
considering that might have 10 pounds to
spend
so you've still kind of got the same at
every price point you've got someone who
thinks it's too expensive
every price point you've got you've got
someone who'll complain
um so and there's a
there is a a lot of research behind like
lower price point
sales tend to generate a higher
percentage of complaints and problems
and
and all that sort of stuff which we've
seen ourselves as well not to say that
you can't have a seven pound
not an eight pound ten pound ebook but
i'd start a higher price thing first
personally and figure out the selling
part fit because if you can't sell
something to your customers
there's probably something going on
deeper level rather than it's
more than ten pounds one of the things
that's interesting there that most
people don't realize
is price isn't just the transaction of
how much the customer pays
it's also a massive signal to that
customer of what they're paying for
that price is an indicator of quality
that's why a pair of nikes cost a
hundred pounds but a pair of like
high-techs costs less i don't know how
much pair of high-techs cost
done i was really going back to like
what what are the [ __ ] shoes i remember
from 20 years ago done
um yeah you get what you pay for and
that is another piece of information you
have to think that the way that
customers
look at your website they're looking at
everything they're looking at the sales
copy they're looking at the imagery
what does it look like what are the
colors like has someone put a ridiculous
soundtrack
over the top of this is the video well
shot and then the price is also another
okay so
all of these different things tell me
something about
the business and person that is trying
to take my money from me
the price is also another indicator of
that and i think that you're right
the presumption on the internet even if
people
like your mum and my mom aren't
explicitly aware
i think everyone knows that the costs on
the internet generally are lower
which means that if the amount of money
that's being charged is still
super super low you've just got this
sort of ick factor this level of of
mistrust
and i get it as well even having seen
taken the red pill and sort of seen
through the
the other side of the curtain about this
stuff i still see something i'm like
that's 15 pounds that can't be worth any
value
you go hang in a second like maybe maybe
it is but
that compulsion that that sort of sense
that you get the
response as a customer should tell you
everything that you need to know so yeah
i would
i would agree on that um what are the
markers of a good and a bad sales funnel
let's say that someone has now been
convinced
they say right i understand the product
i understand need to have product market
fit
it's worked with a few people started to
build something up and now i'm i'm going
to maybe start converting some slightly
less
hot leads some warm leads that i've got
that i know some friends or maybe even
starting to post out to the wider
internet
i need to build a sales funnel what are
the principles around making it good
and making it bad it's a big question
um so i suppose the like the most
important thing about
anything like that especially if you're
thinking i'm gonna
try and live off this is just
repeatability
um like if if a sales process works
because
like you're like a guy who you met once
his mate went through it and bought from
you and they're like oh my sales funnel
work
like in there needs to be some aspect of
you know once um every month i get about
this many customers or i make
about this many sales when i do these
things and then you that's like a
foundation to build on
so repeatability does it consistently
work
um it's quite hard to say like this is
the best sales approach or this
is the best way to do it because that's
very different market to market
some things might just require a page
that explains what it is
with a video that explains how it works
other things are a bit more of a
commitment might
might require a bit more contact with
the person they might involve a phone
call
they might involve a group call or
something like that so
i think i would to to start of where
should i
where should i begin i would think about
who's the person that i'm
trying to sell to and how do they
normally make decisions
right so if it's a personal trainer in a
gym like how does this person normally
make a decision well they might go to
the gym
for a trial session so well okay i can't
do that on the internet
so how am i going to create this same
feeling as like more as getting a
a walk through of what it might be like
or an experience of what it might be
like
so you're mimicking a customer's
decision right
so that's a probably the best way of
giving a general answer is it should be
you should be able to rely on it really
and if you can't it's not really doing
the job that it needs to
in in running the business and it should
as closely as possible
match what the customer needs to make a
decision
if someone needs longer than a day to
make a decision but you try and make
everyone and make it you try and make
everyone make the decision in a day it's
not going to work
so that's how i would think of it
in that situation where someone takes
longer than a day to make the decision
you could perhaps have an email sequence
over
seven days or over 14 days that would
slowly
explain to them the different benefits
or perhaps even provide some free advice
around whatever it is that you're
talking about exactly and that might
convince someone
whereas creating a 14-day
uh set of email sequences for a 10-pound
ebook on something that's very
transactional and someone can learn in
half an hour
kind of makes a lot less sense yeah
that's spot on and i think like
you and i have both bought courses books
programs online before
right so we are probably both of us on
the side of the
spectrum which is skeptical need
quite a lot of convincing or like i need
you to come up to me and say
you should buy this thing right i'm not
the sort of person who's gonna
make a decision very quickly but some
people do and i think generally the way
that we operate is
there's usually three percent five
percent of any
round of people who are just looking for
someone to help them
right they're not they're not in the
browsing phase they're in the i'm going
to buy one of these
i'm just picking which one right i'm
just i'm literally online
weight loss program best online pt
course best yep whatever just
literally looking to buy something right
so
those people probably don't need six
months right because actually if you
wait six months
they'll abort from somebody else if
someone's looking for a consultant a
program a product
anything and you are there and you speak
to that person in a way that kind of
makes them feel like you're a good
you're a good choice
you can make some sales pretty quickly
but there are also people who'll just
click on
something because it's the internet and
people do it passively well netflix is
on the background right
they'll click on something an opt-in but
not really make a decision for a year
so you need the the shorter window but
also a way of kind of keeping in touch
with people so as you mentioned email
sequences or that would be when
a podcast or a youtube channel or
something like that comes in handy
so there's a lot to this but basically
it comes down to
what does my customer need from me to
make a decision about this
whether that's now or in six months time
and how do i create that experience in
my business
so that if someone is just browsing if
you imagine a
shop situation if every person came in
the shop the shop assistant went up to
them and pushed them against the wall
and went you've got to buy this now
otherwise the timer's going to run out
they'd probably go to jail
right i imagine eventually they'd go to
jail um whereas if it's like hey can i
help you
do you want a free sample like have you
seen this have this brochure
can i get your email address you want to
be on our email list like what a nice
experience when i am ready to buy i'm
going to go back to that shop
it's it's thinking about it like that
there's not there's no magical
three-step script that makes this all
work it's just people buying from people
so you've got to mimic that as closely
as possible what we've talked about a
lot so far has been
i would guess mostly conversions product
market fit making sure that people come
in
the right they understand what you're
trying to sell them that they don't get
too put off
what about traffic i need people to
actually see the thing that i'm trying
to sell them how can i drive traffic
so this is something that chris and i
have like
discussed on and off for since i've
known you so i'm i'm mr ads
and chris is mr organic basically so for
people who don't know what those terms
mean
like ads paying for i pay
facebook instagram google whatever for
something to appear
and everyone's seen the word sponsored
underneath an instagram post right
organic would just be using a following
that you have and i guess they require
different approaches
and different
different strategies and tactics so you
can basically do one of those two things
you can run ads to something you can pay
to target a specific type of person who
has a specific interest to come and
visit your customer journey
right or you can take a a less
direct approach and try and build things
organically by getting getting traction
so you can have platforms and channels
online
instagram is i guess maybe slightly
slightly on the downhill it's hard to
say a lot of people are building
platforms on twitter these days youtube
channels podcasts
and you send that traffic those people
those clicks
to where you know if i send 100 people
here
one of them will buy generally speaking
or you're so confident in
the sales sequence that you've built
that you know
for sure from the last thousand people
that one in 10 people buy
right and if one in 10 people buy and i
know if i spend 100 pounds i make
150 then there's a pretty strong
argument to then use advertising to just
get people to come in through the door
because you know you can very
closely control who comes and sees you
right who comes and finds the sales
sequence because you can basically
select interests and demographics and
all that sort of stuff so that that's
the traffic side of things and and
all of these uh words like conversions
and traffic
and the optimization of them are worlds
in
in and of themselves there's lots
there's lots to them
we opt more for paid because it's
a bit easier to control and i guess
yusuf and i quite introverted don't
necessarily want to post that pose our
top stuff all the time
i'm like suited to being behind a a
spreadsheet in a graph
whereas i guess chris has been very
successful with the opposite
so those are kind of two examples of how
you might go and get
attention to your business once it's
built once it's functioning
what's your current opinion on the
online platforms for organic
in six years ago everyone wanted a
facebook page and three years ago
everyone wanted an instagram and
now tick tock is taking off sort of
where are we at at the moment
what do you think is useful to use now
and then what's your predictions for the
next sort of five to ten years in terms
of whether
the power for organics going to be i
think we
probably agree on this i think and that
i think search-based content is going to
be
the the dominant thing and by search
based
if you imagine instagram twitter
facebook they're feed-based
social media so like you don't
necessarily search on instagram for
something or search on facebook for
something
a podcast a youtube video an article
blog posts that sort of stuff
um is like someone types something into
youtube because they follow someone on
youtube or they follow a podcast
or maybe they read a blog regularly for
example um
you can make something once on those
platforms and it
i mean i'm sure you've got some crazy
stats over your
some of your videos the higher
performing ones where it's been made a
year ago
and still every day a thousand people
are finding it a thousand people are
finding it and there's a new people
every single day
um i think they'll always be a feed
based social media
and they'll always be like something
that's in vogue
i know like clubhouse is the is
something that's
gradually gaining traction tick tocks
obviously replaced
always going head to head with instagram
reels and stuff like that
that i think it's a dangerous game to
get involved with because those
platforms can
can die overnight like we saw facebook
pages
facebook business pages were the thing
like six seven years ago
and now you can barely get anybody to
see a post if you post on facebook
so i think it'll be a long time before
people stop searching things on google
people stop searching things on youtube
whereas i think people can leave social
media platforms
very very quickly with a bad bit of
press i've never i've never thought
about it like that but that's a
such a good um way to put it so do you
see
almost the search based stuff which
would be
articles hosted on blogs um going
through google
youtube which is also owned by google
and also the second most popular search
engine in the world
and also appears within google results
so youtube's also kind of somehow
a google um yeah that's the same thing
yeah
essentially um podcasts aren't wonderful
on seo but they're not bad and they
sometimes appear in there you would put
that stuff into one particular side of
the internet and then
that that's moving at a slightly slower
place the turnover the attrition rate
the churn rate of that
is moving slower than facebook tick tock
instagram clubhouse twitter
etc etc i'd say so yeah so like it
depends on sort of the the age of people
listening but um
i can remember when all anybody spoke
about
was facebook and then i can remember
when all anybody spoke about was
instagram
and then things gradually die and now
actually most of my friends have deleted
their facebook account
because they saw some like woke netflix
documentary that makes them think
they're being manipulated
right so you know i mean but but it's
amazing this isn't how that can happen
how there's just a little bit of bad
press about something and people like
right i'm on facebook
isn't it interesting no one's deleted
their youtube account
like no one has stopped watching youtube
precisely
precisely yeah i just i thought this the
other day it wouldn't surprise me
if elon musk doesn't have
a facebook account um and he deleted
tesla's facebook page on a whim yep
and yet him and jeff bezos
when they're sat somewhere at three in
the morning because they've got jetlag
because they've just traveled halfway
across the world on the private jet
will 100 watch videos on youtube
there isn't there isn't a chance in hell
but there is a pretty big chance in hell
that they wouldn't watch tick tock
so yeah it seems more ubiquitous the the
search base is platforms
and you've got to consider like i you
know people have bad things to say about
google
but they also have gmail and chrome
so for like those behaviors to stop
it's going to take real shifts because
because what's interesting is when
someone deletes a facebook account they
don't then
spend no time on their phone they just
replace that habit with
instagram or tick tock or something else
right whereas
if you're searching for something or you
follow a youtuber
you just follow that content right
because it's interesting and you don't
you don't go on youtube with this like
oh this is
i mean yeah it's easy to spend five
hours on youtube but it kind of feels
better
than spending five hours on instagram
like it's so hard to explain why isn't
it like it feels like time better spent
so here's my here's one potential
proposal for that
the number of people who have accounts
versus the number of people who create
content for the platform
on youtube is more uh there's more
inequality in that than probably on
anything else
almost almost no one that's listening
has ever uploaded a video to youtube
and yet no one wow no
no one that's listening hasn't ever
watched something on youtube the same
can't be said for facebook or instagram
like you know sometimes you
wish that your dad would stop posting on
facebook like dad not again
like but the like you're like dad stop
stop uploading your channel man
yeah stop stop putting vlogs on youtube
like that that doesn't happen so i i
certainly think that basically what you
have
is a channel with more
higher barriers to entry to create the
content for it because anyone can take a
photo
upload it to instagram but because this
race to ever increase in quality saves
the guy
shooting this on a dslr camera with a
studio quality microphone
um the race to ever higher quality
because there is so much money to be
made on youtube and other similar
platforms if you get it right
has meant that it's almost if you to say
to someone hey man like i need you to
film a vlog
are you being serious like a film a vlog
of myself that's logan paul territory
that's mike thurston territory
but if you to say hey man take we put
that on your story take yourself and put
it on your story
but that probably highlights where the
value is felt and also the evergreen
nature of the platforms
so that thing from david perel almost
90 percent of the content that you
consume today
will have been created within the last
24 hours
like that statistic should terrify
everybody
because it just means if it's easy come
it's easy go it's probably pointless
you're not going to remember you're not
even going to remember that you consumed
it
whereas if you've got something which
has been around for a little bit longer
it's most likely going to be of
worthwhile content if it's popped up on
your radar after having been on the
internet for three years
you're like all right well you know it's
accumulated half a million views over
three years perhaps this is actually
worth retiring it probably is because
it's been selected for by other people
as opposed to another booty
selfie photo from like that girl that
you follow on instagram
i think the i never thought about the
comparison of
most people know someone who uploads to
instagram instagram regularly whereas
like
i i literally can think of you in terms
of my my social circle who posts on
youtube
it's you so i think part of that is
a podcast and youtube are like a step
down from
tv and radio in terms of how it's
perceived so for someone to think
to be on youtube that's like whoa like i
can't put myself on youtube that's like
being on tv same with a podcast
a lot of people have nerves about being
on a podcast
so i mean it it's just one of those
things where
i would happily spend all day on youtube
because of the amount of stuff i can
learn
and i think because of that and because
you can find a video that's 10 years old
and still be really valuable
the incentive is to is to
pour your heart into this like piece of
art that might still be exist in 10
years time whereas
your instagram story isn't going to last
more than 24 hours imagine
imagine if you watched someone's
instagram post or if you got delivered
someone's instagram post from 10 years
ago you go what
what is this doing on my phone why is
this here i don't want to know
i don't want to know about that meal
that they had a decade ago like that's
the point yes
but the video that they made on youtube
might be different okay so
organic and paid we understand that we
understand that traffic is getting
people
to see the thing and conversions is
getting people that see the thing to buy
the thing
is there anything else that we haven't
spoken about are there any loose ends to
tie up here
so i suppose the part that we've not
covered is is actually providing the
the product or the service um which is
harder to to speak generally about
because that
it's gonna depend right um i the the
the traps that i would avoid are um
view it as yes this is great when i've
got
three customers i'm gonna put everything
into these three customers they're going
to get the most bespoke experience i'm
going to call them every morning i'm
going to make sure
you know but that at 30 customers
starts actually becoming a worse service
a worse way of living your life
the 31st customer's got to wait for the
31st email
reply and if you're answering the same
questions over and over again or
delivering the same service that gets
watered down all the time
you just start to resent it and i think
where where we nearly got to with
propane was at the point where
it was like we just don't enjoy doing
this which circles back to my point of
like what do you want your day to look
like
if you build your business and how you
work with your customers around that
assumption
and the platforms you pick and you end
up enjoying it and you end up doing it
for a long time so
i can't really say this is how you run
an online business because the specifics
of the delivery will vary a lot but
i would always consider what would
happen if
i for some reason this dis really
started succeeding and i had doubled my
customers by this time next week would i
be able to actually fulfill that
because if your systems aren't scalable
then it'll just break and you'll hate it
basically
is there an argument to be made at the
beginning being a little bit closer to
the customer
is a good idea to get more of that quick
iterative feedback
so i know that you guys did this when
you first started out although
you look back on it now and cringe at
the amount of time that you
spent slash wasted i also think
there is value in that because it gives
you such a
close-up highly magnified look at the
inner workings of a
client customer a client coach
relationship or this could be for
anybody this could be someone who
is helping someone to start up their own
small medium-sized business in the real
world
like understanding the pains that that
person goes through
as they begin to do it helps you to see
down the line so perhaps
do you think that might be a a way to
not not necessarily look to future-proof
yourself
to the 10-year goal but to maybe just
have a trajectory of how you could start
dropping things away
definitely yeah so i think there's
absolutely
there's nothing wrong with working
closely with your customers to get
feedback and ideas and
and all that sort of stuff generally
like what we advise now is if you're
working with someone closely initially
and they say i don't understand how this
works or can you explain this a bit
better overall
um what do you think about this see that
as an opportunity to
create a resource for that question or
something that is a
i'm going to answer this question once
to the best of my ability and then it's
the best answer to that question ever
or it's the the best explanation
walkthrough of this ever rather than oh
yeah good question mate let me just
write a long email for you and press
send and then it's going to disappear
forever
so yeah absolutely the more you can know
your customers
the better your service is going to be
the more the happier everyone will be
did you
see did you see derek sivers when he
talks about what he did at cd baby with
customer inquiries
no so cd baby was the one of the biggest
online stores selling music cds derek
sivers
who has been on the show
multi-multi-millionaire also a friend of
tim ferriss and just generally
interesting human
every time that a customer rang this is
after he
understood this particular problem he
was coming up against that he was
constantly spinning his wheels doing the
same things over and over
he made a decision that he was going to
create a um
operating procedure for the whole
business for everything that he did
and every single time that a customer
rang excuse me
my cds arrived and it's correct excuse
me my cd is being delivered to my
neighbor excuse me
whatever whatever whatever whatever the
issues are i can't play it i put it in
upside down i've done whatever
every time that that happened he stopped
the whole office
and said right everybody this is how
it's going to happen this is what the
answer is these are the particular
routes that you go down
and he had someone write it as well and
over the course of
some months i can't remember how many
months he'd created this how to be
derek dot doc booklet
which was all of the things that he
ended up encountering
and then he left the business he left
the business for six months and
and nothing nothing went wrong and he
was ringing them and they were like what
are you ringing for
we're fine leave us alone we've got work
to do um that's very tim ferriss
yes so that that's such an interesting
insight and it's one that
me and darren learned later than we
would have liked but still earlier than
we could have done
that most of the problems that you're
going to come up against in any business
actually forget just online most of the
problems you're going to come up against
are consistent challenges that you're
going to face not just
once but probably monthly or
every couple of months for the rest of
the time that you run this business
and the person who will inevitably end
up sitting below you or to the side of
you
it is easier for you to write the
perfect way
in this in the fewest number of words
and the most precise language possible
how you deal with this thing and then
you can just give it to a person
and it's basically like taking your
knowledge out of your brain and giving
it to them
i can't remember who it was that i was
reading that
said the job of a owner or managing
director is basically to be a complex
decision engine that can never be
matched by anybody else
so if you actually think about what your
role as business owner is
you're taking in a million different
inputs
like the the the way that that customer
looked when he walked into the nightclub
and
how the dj played his last half hour and
the the amount of mess on the floor of
plastic glass
waste and whether the this many people
went home with the inflatables or
without and none of these things
using my industry as an example i'm not
noting any of those down i don't have
them quantified anywhere
but they do appear in consciousness and
they will aggregate together to give me
a sense of what is going on and then
when we sit down and we talk about the
event the next day
i can say things that stayed in
consciousness
and i actually did notice quite a big
weight at the bar sort of between 12 and
12 30. oh yeah
actually what happened we ran out of iso
it says okay can we fix the ice machine
ready for next week is there a way that
we can get bags of icing already
utilizing all of those different things
is your job but what you find is that
more and more
that is the only place that you add
value especially as you move
up through the echelons of a business
that's the only place you can add value
because there will be someone half your
age
in a decade's time that can come and do
the thing that you used to take pride on
to do with
optimizing facebook ads or writing copy
or doing whatever
that thing you used to think that you
were the best at you're now going to be
not even halfway up the company at
the thing that you the thing that you
can't be competed out with
is your experience and your ability to
take those multiple things in
and by writing the document it permits
you to get
other people to do what they can do and
leaves you
to do what only you can in the business
it's the the thing that like every time
you go through mcdonald's drive through
you get given a big mac that's largely
the same as the last big mac
and the next big mac and that's the same
in london manchester
new york and like but it's not ray kroc
making the big back right and that's
really like when you really think about
that that's
incredible that like there is such a
process like even the way
mcdonald's is laid out and the way the
drive-through works and the window that
you pay out and all that sort of stuff
so that
that's someone taking this is how to run
a
mcdonald's out of their head and making
a document that can literally be copied
and pasted around the world
um but it's there's a book called the
e-myth revisited that
that goes into this and it's so hard to
do it's so hard to
to come to terms with the fact that what
you think you're good at is actually
just
a recipe that you can write down give to
someone else and they might even be
better than you
and all you have to do is like actually
it might the challenge for me is just
picking a better person me to do the
thing that i thought of and then
i'm just gonna slowly creep away
that's a that's a good point if there's
someone listening that thinks this
sounds all right i might
give the online business stuff a crack
other than going to propane fitness.com
modern wisdom what are the books that
you think would have the best
impact on someone's insight
so i think you've got to read the
four-hour work week to be honest i think
it's it's such a
the way of it's a way of thinking about
it i think that's very important and tim
talks about
exactly what we just spoke about this
idea of working towards taking mini
retirements
so he uses an example of when he i think
his business was called brain quicken i
think it was a supplement business
he built it up and he he gave virtual
assistants
thresholds of like you can spend up to
200 to solve this problem do not ring me
unless it is absolutely unless it's
above a 200 and then he went on
just went away and left everything and
proved that this could be done
so i think that's a very important way
to think about it from day one and then
the e-myth revisited
walks through this example of pretty
much what we've spoken about although
not online
of a lady who has a passion about baking
so she sets up a bakery and then before
she knows it she's spending more time
like
filing her taxes doing the accounts
cleaning the services and actually
doesn't do any baking at all
and hates it right and part of that is
is realizing that
in setting up a business this is not
just the core thing
that you that you like doing it's not
just training clients it's like all of
the other
support stuff so probably those two
books they're very very commonly uh
very commonly recommended but they're
they're very good like
founding sets of principles um that
they're both quite accessible as well
right yeah yeah
there's a there is a book that i've not
read yet which is on my list of things
to read i think it's called made in
america
by sam walton i believe who's the
i may have got those names wrong but
he's the guy who founded walmart
who talks about this idea that's then
been popularized by
jeff bezos which is this idea of a of a
flywheel
or kind of how amazon the bigger amazon
gets the better amazon gets
and it's on this like runaway snow
snowball that so like
people buy from amazon because there's
loads of trucks
on amazon the more people buy from
amazon the more people sell on amazon
which means there's more choice in
amazon which means more people buy from
amazon and the whole thing just
gets away from itself um so like
that sort of stuff as well learning from
big uh ceos
like watching interviews with with
people who've done it it's always really
interesting they always have
recommendations as well
but i'll start with those two books i
would say cool man
i like it i i i wish that i'd uh
had the insights that i do now and
hopefully it's cut through some of the
[ __ ] for people today
like all of the stuff that you spend
time when you start a business
especially if you're young especially if
you're listening to this and you're 20
years old
and you've never done a business before
and you're thinking about
do i need to be a limited company do i
need to
register for tax and vat and an
accountant it's like
you have a paypal the internet doesn't
need you
to do anything more than that start
iterating on what it is and here's a
quote i read a couple of these from
yesterday i don't know whether you saw
them on them
on my instagram tiago forte
a paradoxical thing about people who
consistently choose the most high
leverage activity
is their efforts have a rough edged
half-assed quality
because polishing things to perfection
is a low leverage activity
and someone commented underneath saying
perfectionism is a nice way to hide
from shipping at a pace necessary to
find what works
i love that i really really agree with
that
this is something that um so
the the thing we spoke about right at
the start of like just
if you've got an idea like sell it and
then build it with your customers
and you'll end up building a better
product that's something that i'm always
pushing used to limits on it's like he
always wants to have something half
perfect and then sell it
but you hear so many people talk about
like just
like anybody can sit and procrastinate
anybody can sit and try and perfect
something anybody can sit and
tweak the color scheme but if you just
launch it if you just get it out there
and you do it
quicker than your competitor you'll
probably be ahead in a year's time
do you love that the other thing as well
is you run out of motivation
usually at getting something from 90
percent perfect
to 100 perfect far more than doing
another 90
perfect thing of the same thing yeah so
for instance
i'm eating some frogs at the moment with
this youtube stuff
and still finding my workflow and then
sat myself down and had a bit of a word
with myself at the beginning of the year
i was like look
you're going to encounter like so much
discomfort you're going to get
frustrated at yourself you're going to
feel like you're incapable of doing what
it is
just keep getting yourself to good
enough
and ship it and get it too good enough
and ship it and over time good enough
will continue to increase
um and i've found keeping that in mind
keeping that little mantra that it's
like look yeah maybe
you don't like the way you said this or
the edit could be a bit more that
but it's it's like it's there and you've
learned you've
gleaned most of the learning you had to
from that particular iteration i'm aware
that this works
more easily when it's a youtube video
that
goes out three times a week or a podcast
that goes out three times a week as
opposed to a big product that's maybe
taking you six months to do
but even with that asking quickly for
bits of feedback doing a glass door
policy which has been championed by jack
butcher
at jack butcher on twitter for the um
people who aren't initiated into his
little cult
um he has very much a glassdoor policy
around his business
he happily tells people what his daily
revenue is
how he's building things where he's
going next what the next course is that
he's going to release
and i think part of it is because his
success is a humble brag
which makes him increase in status and
people want to be attached to him
but the other side of it is that he gets
constant feedback from the market saying
actually mate why are you giving us a
course about
how to do design another course about
design i don't want that i want one
about mindset or i want one about this
thing
um and yeah the what is it that yousef
says
idea is the constant delivery is the
multiplier
it may be i've never heard him say that
before but it's not his quote he's
quoting someone else
but the point is everyone always
considers that they've got this idea
this really unique
way um it's going to be like fitnesswear
but it's like vegan
and it's in like sustainable packaging
um and
all of the clothes are going to be
purple and like it's every pound of a
sale goes to a dog and whatever
like that's the thing but what people
idea is the constant execution is the
multiplier
and people don't realize that it is all
about the execution
that for the most part you can have the
best
idea for youtube video in the world but
if your execution of it is awful then
no one's going to listen and the same
thing goes for pretty much every
other online product it's the person
walking around the
tate gallery in london i could have done
that
so well yes but
someone did and i love where they are
like i know you could have taken a photo
of a cow
in that way and i'm sure it would have
done very well but ultimately you didn't
so it kind of removes the it like
removes the ability to criticize
it's the and the person who says that
they thought of uber before uber was
made and all that all those sorts of
things so yeah i fully agree
and the other thing about that as well
is like only you know what the 100
might have looked like no one else knows
that what that your
80 percent was actually 100 and if
you've got any criticisms
great like it was only 80 percent
perfect so i could i've got room to
improve
yeah that's a really really good point
as well
that was something i was thinking of the
other day that it is only you that ever
feels the lack of potential that you
fulfilled within a project
because to everyone else from the
outside looking in they just think well
that's the
that's the product service course sales
funnel video podcast that's the thing
don't think oh well that could have been
the thing but actually he's half-assed
it and given us it
at this stage so yeah man i love it a
nice reminder of
that just to wrap up nice reminder that
principle that i'm faced with all the
time
is every time i launch an ad campaign
four images and i always guess i'm like
that one's gonna do best and i'm every
single time i'm wrong
even after even after getting it wrong
consistently and learning which one
won and using that information going
forward i've still never been right
so like your idea of what other people
are going to think is good
is very very rarely the case so 80
of it do it and people respond either
positively or negatively
and that's the only really the only way
to progress
so i love you man i love it how not to
start an online business
people want to check out stuff about
propane and what you do where do they go
what do they get
so i've i've just been lovely again and
done something
special for you which is nice isn't it
so we did a training the other day um
which is more general
um it's still still for online fitness
business mainly but it's kind of more
if you're sat there thinking i'd like to
give this a crack but i'm not sure where
to start
um it's more from the ground up
principles base covers everything that
we just spoken about in a bit more
detail so that is at
propanefitness.com forward slash mw
business you can go and grab that free
training
yours forever um in terms of following
us in general
probably the best places is uh we have
two podcasts
we have a fitness podcast and a business
podcast uh we talk about
as you my guest fitness and business uh
or our youtube channel just search
uh propane fitness on youtube and on the
youtube channel actually you'll find
links to both the podcasts as well
so those are the best places don't don't
go to instagram and stuff like that
because
it'll be dead in a couple years
i love that man thank you it's been a
shame not to have sephie but i've
i've thoroughly enjoyed this if you've
got any thoughts comments or feedback
just throw them in the comments below on
youtube or
message johnny on a platform which isn't
instagram
thanks
[Music]
you